merci jean c'est la saison des défilés
de mode encore faut-il pour chaque
créateur se démarquer de son voisin
alors par une collection originale bien
sûr mais aussi par une manière de la
présenter également original et des
mannequins qui arrache comme on dit
familièrement c'est à dire qui vous
enlève une collection qui la porte
c'est une étape très importante pour un
couturier le choix des mannequins dan
moussa l'eau a suivi les postulantes de
jean paul gaultier l'un des plus grands
stylistes français
créateur cherche mannequin pour défilés
de mode blondes et brunes s'abstenir
passionnel en avant l'annoncé des choix
différents signes comme ça mais je peux
tellement le vent mais pourquoi là
pourquoi la petite chaleix ce qu'on
cherche des montants pour le dessiner je
lui montrais mes petites photos de
vacances mais la prière polaroïd parce
que les photos ce n'est pas l'air et
puis voilà mon numéro de téléphone
qui vous a dit de laisser les cheveux
verts jean paul gaultier se veut l'homme
de la mode du futur il échappe aux lois
de la pesanteur et cette année place les
femmes en orbite autour de la planète
rousse elle par contre va cacher ses
cheveux qui sont pas assez roues dans le
cas chaque un postiche pour avoir plus
d'effets sur scène
première et dernière répétition avant le
défilé dans quelques minutes les
mannequins du futur sont lâchés dans
l'espace intersidéral
j'aime récupérer après
les élégantes de l'espace ont choisi des
scaphandres panoramique pour leur
cocktail intergalactique pour chokling
stellaire des panier à provisions demi
lune
sous leur combinaison certaines coquette
reste fidèle aux formes classiques de
notre bonne vieille terre dans le cosmos
les femmes ne sortent plus leurs bijoux
mais le vêtement deviennent sculpture et
la perruque devient une parure même pour
les femmes du futur la guêpière et le
corset reste des armes de séduction
gauthier à la recherche de nouvelles
formes des nouvelles matières d'une
autre femme
mais le créateur n'est-il pas toujours à
la recherche de lui-même
voilà comment